foreign
journalism used to be a working class
profession
um you don't there's nothing like
there's nothing there's not rocket
science behind writing a news article
you just figure out what's going on and
you write it down right you need a high
school degree for that
that's it it's not a skill that you need
a credential for it's a skill that you
can develop it's like more of like an
apprentice style model and creating a
kind of a graduate degree which is what
you know this Columbia journalism school
is sort of in an existential crisis
because you know they have a nine month
degree that costs 120 hundred ten
hundred twenty thousand dollars and
they're like are we the problem and it
was like yeah you guys are the problem
you're not the only problem you're more
of a symptom really there's something
underlying there's there's there's some
money there's like someone's making a
lot of money here and that's what's
causing me this problem and it's
probably a large group of people that
are making a bunch of money or higher ed
is just such a mess
um in terms of the administrative bloat
there is a scam there
um and I haven't been able to figure out
what that scam is but obviously it
should not cost 120 000 for a nine month
program
um just like it shouldn't cost a hundred
and whatever thousand dollars to go to
law school or to or to get an
undergraduate degree or any of these
other things it's like there is
something going on here that we need
real investigations
you know to figure out the source of the
high cost of of these higher education
institutions
you also have to ask what is the point
of Education in general or higher
education in general and you know I
think the idea that it's it's there to
get you a job is it's always you know
that's sort of a practical reason to go
to school but more fundamentally I think
that schooling exists to make citizens
and
um uh to to build a moral society that a
self-governing society and also it's
there to let you get a job and build a a
life right that's you know these are
these are integrated
um and I think that we're falling down
on sort of on all counts of that they
are is settling people with a lot of
debt right I mean you can't come out of
a school with lots of debt and be a good
citizen like you are now a dependent on
someone else right you should come out
of school maybe with a little bit of
debt maybe with no debt I mean there
have been times in American history when
all this has been free who certainly
High School is free
um so I think that the financial aspects
of college
of higher education have overwhelmed the
um the ability to create a citizenry